current energy secretary Rick Perry is
not a fan of the Department of Energy in
fact he wanted to end the Department of
Energy when he was running for president
not that long ago he now runs the
department he wanted to end but don't
worry he's determined to do damage in
spite of being employed by that
department now if you are Energy
Secretary you should be forward-looking
you should consider the long-term impact
of your decisions and Rick Perry is
actually doing the exact opposite he has
a plan to kill funding for wind and
solar power the correct reaction would
be wait a second we're currently funding
wind and solar power and the answer is
yeah I know it sounds weird because you
know that we heavily subsidized oil and
other forms of dirty energy we do sort
of fund wind and solar power to a degree
but not like the subsidies on dirty
energy including oil coal and natural
gas but we do and that's what Rick Perry
wants to cut down on there's a study due
out very very soon which is the goal of
figuring out whether federal tax and
subsidy policies favoring renewable
energy have burdened quote baseload
coal-fired generation putting power grid
reliability at risk this is a study
that's being spearheaded by Energy
Department political appointee Travis
Fischer who is associated with a
Washington policy group I'm sure you
know where I'm going with this drain the
swamp right associated with a group that
opposes almost any government aid for
renewable energy to give you some more
context about the person running the
study Fischer wrote a paper a report two
years ago for the Institute for energy
research which called clean energy
policies quote quote the single greatest
emerging threat to the nation's
electrical power grid a greater threat
than cyberattacks terrorism or extreme
weather the Institute for energy
research and its advocacy arm the
American energy Alliance have been the
influential force in shaping Trump's
plan to dismantle Obama's climate
initiative so we fully come full circle
here the American President through his
cabin
is doing everything he can to get coal
jobs back while China is becoming the
clean-air leader of the world or sort of
going in that direction anyway this is
government versus technology this is
government versus the environment but
this is also a republican government
against the free market that is that is
the angle that is being lost here which
is by wanting to prop up coal Donald
Trump is going against the free market
which suggests dying industry let it die
well you know what right-wingers will
say that it's unfair to compare
renewable energy and the success that
wind and solar has had versus the
decline of coal because while we've
subsidized wind and solar we've placed
so many burdensome regulations on coal
and that's why you see that industry
failing yes regulations like you have to
try really hard not to kill tons of
people through the energy production
that you're doing right and of course
they will ignore the fact that those
dirty fossil fuels and power generation
from them are and have been heavily
heavily subsidized for a long time and
I've given you the employment numbers
right solar now employs more people in
American electricity generation than oil
coal and gas combined the entire coal
industry employs fewer people than RVs
and employs fewer people than JCPenney
as Pat has recently mentioned to us if
argued correctly this should appeal to
right-wingers let China take the lead on
this no that jeopardizes American
exceptionalism it jeopardizes American
business when other countries start
going to China for advice and contracts
on renewable energy that's embarrassing
to the United States isn't that the sort
of nationalistic logic that should
appeal to the right well is it really
fair to subsidize one form of energy
while you're penalizing another that's a
fair question I mean we if you're going
to stop funding wind and solar be fair
and stop funding oil and gas as well
right I mean why should taxpayers have
to be burdened with subsidies at all and
it's sort of it's a rhetorical question
but it also isn't right why why are we
playing favorites in a way that is very
very much anti-free market and nuclear
we are going to be doing a really
interesting piece on on nuclear and I
don't want to say anything else and we
might be going nucular as george w bush
used to like to say after that piece
today's episode of the david pakman show
is made possible in part by Warby Parker
eyeglasses Warby Parker recently did the
right thing and ditched advertising on
right-wing conspiracy website Breitbart
pulling their ads off and you can get
the free five-day home Tryon from Warby
Parker check out their glasses I use
them when I'm not wearing contact lenses
I started with the free at-home trial
they send you five pairs of glasses you
see which ones you like you send them
back and whichever one you pick they
will put your prescription in - I like
this because I can actually show the
glasses to other people and not have to
just decide on the spot like in an
eyeglass store the eyeglass industry is
controlled by very few corporations that
keep the prices very very high even over
$300 for prescription glasses with Warby
Parker they start at just 95 bucks mine
cost that including lenses and for every
pair sold they give a pair to someone in
need so to try the five pairs and
support the David Pakman show go to
Warby Parker trial comm /t DPS